[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 19 octobre voici
les titres de l'actualité locale
quatre jours avec au programme ateliers
webinaire y job dating ce qui emploie
fait sa rentrée se déroule jusqu'à jeudi
3000 offres sont à pourvoir près de 100
entreprises recrutent 7 organisé par
saint quentin en yvelines et colas d'un
deal vice président de l'agglomération
est notre invité première poutre posée
il ya quelques jours pour la cité
champeau à chanteloup-les-vignes cet
événement symbolique marque le coup
d'envoi d'une importante opération de
renouvellement urbain dans la commune du
nord du département le nom de ce projet
la cité éducative simone veil
et puis les belles carrosseries étaient
de sortie et ce samedi à la verrière la
commune et le must en club de france ont
organisé un rassemblement dédié à la
plus célèbre des voitures américaines
balader baptême était au menu de cet
événement caritatif nous avons pu
embarquer pour un tour en vallée de
chevreuse
et dans cette édition également retour
sur la première édition du festival des
mots les feuilles d'automne c'était au
programme ce week-end à rambouillet
[Musique]
et j'accueille dès à présent mon invité
nicolas dainville bonsoir
le maire de la verrière alors avec vous
on va pas parler de ce rassemblement de
mustang qui étaient au programme dans
votre commune ce week-end les
téléspectateurs soyez patients c'est
dans quelques minutes avec un reportage
au programme à la fin de ce journal
nicolas dainville vous êtes également le
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en chances de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
l'agglomération qui je le disais dans
les titres organise en ce moment le ski
emploi fait sa rentrée ce a débuté hier
ça va se dérouler sur quatre jours au
programme des ateliers des webinaires un
hit job dating également pour clôturer
cet événement avec 3000 offres d'emploi
à trouver on va en parler dans un
instant tout d'abord ce reportage après
une période de pandémie l'heure est
aujourd'hui à la relance pour les
employeurs comme pour les postulants les
conditions semblent favorables à
l'emploi m et pour optimiser ses chances
de trouver le bon salarié ou la bonne
entreprise selon le camp il est possible
d'adapter son offre regardez ce
reportage de bixente manière centriste
et banner de patrick jacques de dixmude
l'objectif c'est pouvoir évoluer pouvoir
dire les
emploient des stagiaires des formations
liées à la formation des apprentis dans
les quartiers ya beaucoup de talent il
ya beaucoup de potentiel si maintenant
on leur donne leur chance et qu'on les
accompagne correctement forcément y'a
pas de raison que ça se passe pas une
réunion pour l'emploi au ski cuba
guyancourt les entreprises étaient
présentes ce lundi 18 octobre pour
échanger autour de la thématique
recruter autrement les enjeux pour nous
c'est à la fois permettre aux
entreprises de retrouver la dynamique
qui était la leur avant que vite comme
je vous le disais aussi peut-être
d'orienter des stratégies de manière un
peu différente en tenant compte des
difficultés qu'on a pu rencontrer dans
les périodes de confinement par exemple
recruter autrement mais aussi postuler
autrement à quelques centaines de mètres
de là lagence option un terrible fait
réaliser des cv vidéo à ses chercheurs
d'emploi elle a créé pour cela le site
au petit cv pour un candidat ça lui
apporte 30 % plus de trouver un cdi par
rapport à un cv papier c'est plus une
vitrine en fait vraiment ça va être la
présentation de candidats c'est une
vitrine sur son expérience
professionnelle ou non choisie que deux
ou trois on ne peut pas tout expliquer
dans mon cv de vidéo de 2 minutes et
puis bah c'est surtout voilà les
motivations et les atouts du candidat le
cv vidéo à la fois un atout moderne pour
un candidat et un gain de temps pour les
entreprises dans leur quête de
recrutement
la tendance allait elle est très
favorable à l'emploi puisque on a une
demande de recrutement qui est qui est
bien plus élevé qu'avant la crise au co
vide aujourd'hui il faut mettre en
adéquation justement ses besoins en
recrutement avec la demande d'emploi sur
saint quentin en yvelines et c'est tout
l'enjeu de ces quatre jours qui sont
dédiés à l'emploi et qui démarre
aujourd'hui de nombreux autres rendez
vous dédié à l'emploi sont organisés du
18 au 21 octobre dans le cadre du ski
emploi fait sa rentrée
et donc ce sont au total 40 événements
sur ce ce qui emploie fait sa rentrée je
vous disais que 3000 offre également
sans employeur qui participent et on en
parle avec nicolas d'un deal vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines pourquoi organiser
justement cet événement quels sont les
objectifs
bien écouter on sort d'une crise
sanitaire qui a été très compliqué d'un
point de vue économique on a des
secteurs en forte tension pour ne citer
que quelques-uns secteurs du commerce de
la santé de l'action sociale de l'aide à
la personne du btp du numérique de
l'hôtellerie des cafés des restaurants
qui commence vous l'avez constaté à
réouvrir et qui sont aujourd'hui en
pénurie de main d'oeuvre de l'industrie
des transports de la logistique et donc
tous ces secteurs là
redémarre ont besoin de main d'oeuvre
est donc tout l'objectif de ces
événements c'est de mieux connecter
l'offre et la demande d'emploi pour
connecter nos employeurs avec ceux qui
recherchent une activité justement ce
lien entre offre et demande vous le
dites avec la crise sanitaire il a été
encore plus mise à mal peut-être
bien évidemment ça a été très compliqué
c'est vrai qu'on avait l'habitude
d'avoir un grand événement vélodrome
avec près de quatre mille offres
d'emploi sur une journée c'est vrai
qu'avec eux le l'événement le la crise
sanitaire on n'a pas pu maintenir cet
événement donc on essaie de s'adapter on
appelle des événements en ligne des ide
job dating pour permettre de connecter
grâce au numérique ceux qui recherchent
un emploi et les employeurs et donc là
cette année il ya un peu de présentiel
un peu de distance yann et ça fait du
bien et c'est important parce que je
vous dis on a quand même un taux de
chômage qui
reste quand même important mais si on
observe une petite décrue on a des
offres d'emploi qui augmente son à près
de deux fois plus d'offres d'emploi ce
mois ci que il y a un an la même période
mais on a des secteurs comme je lé dire
en pénurie en tension qui recherchent
des professionnels et donc c'est
important de les connecter oui
finalement vous le dites ya un paradoxe
avec eux ce chômage qui est toujours
présent mais quand même des offres qui
sont disponibles sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines il ya des
offres aujourd'hui disponible
exactement et pour tous ceux qui
recherchent un emploi ou qui recherchent
un talent on a notamment un site une
plateforme unique une en porte d'entrée
pour ceux qui recherchent un talon sont
ceux qui recherchent une entreprise
c'est ce qui emploie point fr vous avez
près de 1500 offres d'emploi qui sont
répertoriées sur ce site internet on
après d'autres 1000 cv donc pour ceux
qui recherchent un talent vous avez
trente mille personnes qui ont déposé un
cv et vous avez près de 400 entreprises
qui sont présentes donc c'est vraiment
notre porte d'entrée pour
permettre à ceux qui recherchent ou à
ceux qui ont des compétences à offrir de
trouver leur bonheur donc plusieurs
ateliers au programme invite les
téléspectateurs à se rendre sur le site
internet dont vous avez parlé qui s'est
affiché à l'écran pour avoir tout le
programme est notamment aussi une
formation sur le cv vidéo qui peut être
aussi un outil aujourd'hui pour trouver
un emploi saint quentin en yvelines en
rappel justin 17 mille entreprises sur
le territoire 5 45 mille emplois c'est
important pour l'agglomération d'être
initiateurs de ce genre de rendez-vous
d'être facilitateur en quelque sorte
voilà vous l'avez dit on à un territoire
béni des dieux avec les plus belles
entreprises du monde sur des secteurs à
forte valeur ajoutée on arnaud on a un
talent elles sont à airbus sont à sodexo
donc on a beaucoup de sièges sociaux qui
qui recrutent et donc c'est très
important effectivement de mieux
connecter aussi nos jeunes nos jeunes
qui je le dis sont souvent un plan
souffrance si on les recherche
d'apprentissage d'alternance malgré les
aides gouvernementales
on a l'état qui met le paquet sur cette
dimension avec des aides qui vont
jusqu'à 7,8 milles euros pour l'embauché
d'un apprenti en alternance est
malheureusement peu d'entreprises se
saisissent pleinement de ces outils donc
c'est aussi notre rôle mieux relayer les
outils à la disposition des entreprises
et les demandeurs d'emploi ont également
les emplois francs pour tous ceux qui
habitent un quartier en priorité de la
ville qui peuvent bénéficier de baisses
de charge lors de leur embauche donc
tous ces outils faut vraiment qu'on s'en
saisissent et qu'on les relais pour
améliorer les choses avec peut-être
aussi une solution pour ceux ces
difficultés de recrutement c'est la
formation est d'ailleurs cet événement
aussi est dédié à la formation à
l'apprentissage c'est également évoqué
au travers du programme très varié de
cet événement
exactement vous la vidéo on a les plus
belles entreprises du monde on a aussi
une des universités qui cartonne dans le
classement de shanghai qui le classement
de toutes les universités lui vs qq
petit paris saclay et qui maintenant se
classe se hisse au plus haut niveau
mondial on mise aussi sur d'autres
écoles des écoles notamment liés au
numérique on a plusieurs formations qui
sont labellisés et qui sont accessibles
à tous quel que soit votre diplôme quel
que soit votre origine sociale
culturelle vous pouvez avoir accès à des
formations sur des métiers en forte
tension c'est les métiers du numérique
de la cybersécurité notamment de la
donner ou encore de delà de la
communication digitale on a toutes ces
formations qui parfois sont payés par
pôle emploi et qui permettent vraiment
de déboucher sur un emploi durable sur
une thématique en forte croissance
dernière chose le point d'orgue de cet
événement c'est un grand i job dating
qui va se dérouler ce 21 octobre ce
jeudi quel est le programme qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir y retrouver dans cet
ide job dating bah écoutez vous l'avez
dit on pourra avoir des rendez-vous des
rendez vous ciblés avec des entreprises
donc il n'y aura pas de perte de temps
on pourra vraiment avoir un rendez vous
avec l'entreprise où le jeune houleux le
salarié qu'on cherche à recruter il y
aura également la possibilité de poser
toutes ses questions par par tchat il y
aura également des ateliers pour aider à
améliorer sa candidature à travers un cv
plus performants travers une meilleure
préparation de l'entretien d'embauché à
travers une gestion plus optimisée de
son temps bref tout voilà toutes les
dimensions seront abordés les dimensions
pour être plus performant pour mieux
présenter mais également pour être en
contact direct avec un employeur ce qui
emploie fait sa rentrée c'est jusqu'à
jeudi et c'est à saint quentin en
yvelines merci nicolas d'envié d'avoir
été avec nous
merci à vous ils rapporteraient plus
tard on va le voir bien alors le
reportage sur les 800 que c'est promis
et je rappelle que vous êtes le
vice-président saint quentin en yvelines
en charge de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
[Musique]
vendredi dernier dans la commune de
chanteloup les vignes les élus locaux
ont posé la première poutre de la cité
et champeaux dans le quartier de la noé
feu serait c'était une première phase
cette pose de la première poutre d'un
projet plus que plus globale le projet
de renouvellement urbain qui s'insère
dans le programme des sites éducative
initié par l'état en 2019 plus de
détails dans ce sujet de michael et demi
d'euros et de céline chardin
une poutre pour symboliser le coup
d'envoi d'un renouvellement urbain ce
vendredi 15 octobre à chanteloup les
vignes les élus locaux ont lancé la
construction de la cité champeau dans la
commune le site s'inscrit dans le projet
de site éducatif simone veil a cité
champeau c'est la première partie de la
cité éducative de champclos qui est fait
partie d'un plan de renouvellement
urbain qui va s'étaler sur plusieurs
années jusqu'en 2025 2026 et ici c'est
le lieu où les enfants de la cité
éducative seront accueillis avec le tout
le dispositif la belle cité éducative
c'est à dire cette nouvelle façon d'être
tous responsables de l'éducation
la livraison de la cité champeau est
programmée pour la rentrée 2022 le site
aura pour vocation à terme d'accueillir
le pôle adolescents et un pôle
administratif englobant les directions
jeunesse objectif redonner un nouveau
souffle à la ville de 10000 habitants
c'est de donner plus en tout cas
d'apporter des choses non seulement
quantitativement mais qualitativement un
plus sur ces quartiers le plus fragile
pour renforcer le sentiment
d'appartenance pour développer la mixité
sociale pour désenclaver
pour éviter finalement
ce qu'on rencontre encore dans certains
quartiers sert une ségrégation
résidentielle
l'ensemble de la cité éducative simone
veil sera livrée à l'horizon 2025
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également la
condamnation de jean messia par le
tribunal de versailles le polémiste
devra s'acquitter d'une amende de 1500
euros pour injure au préfet des yvelines
en février dernier il avait qualifié
jean jacques brot je cite deux amis des
islamistes sur twitter au moment de la
sphère du professeur didier lemaire à
trappes et jean messia devra également
verser 2000 euros à jean jacques brot au
titre de réparation de préjudice moral
et compte faire appel de cette décision
à noter que demain mercredi c'est un
autre procès qui s'ouvrira à versailles
celui du chantage de la sextape au
préjudice de mathieu valbuena sur le
banc des accusés notamment
l'international français et joueur du
real madrid karim benzema nous en
reparlerons demain dans ce journal dans
quelques mois l'espace rambouillet parce
qu'en gestion privée ouvert depuis à 40
ans ce parc animalier est l'un des plus
importants en ile de france avec plus de
cent mille visiteurs par an trois
opérateurs ont été retenus par l'eau nf
qui gère actuellement le site ils
devront présenter un dossier d'ici
décembre respectant un cahier des
charges précis c'est l'interview express
par justine brésil
[Musique]
cet espace rambouillet pour toujours
avoir plus de visiteurs ou au moins
autant que maintenant ça nécessite les
investissements importants entre 5 et 15
millions de d'investissement est
aujourd'hui malheureusement l'onu n'a
plus les moyens
de les avoir pour pouvoir investir
qui est envisagé c'est qu'effectivement
il y à un transfert de ce service à
l'été 2022 le temps de bien sûr de
d'étudier les offres de discuter avec
les candidats le temps aussi d'avoir les
validation administrative et
réglementaire
[Musique]
des nouveautés possible qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui présente donc ça sera à
chaque opérateur me faire ce projet là
pourquoi pas de l'hébergement et c'est
immersif c'est des choses qui se
développe un peu partout dans certains
parcs animaliers mais ça sera
nécessairement dans le respect un dut
faire que ça restera une forêt domaniale
deuxièmement que ce soit dans l'esprit
est vraiment de l'animal dans dans le
milieu et sur l'aspect et de tous les
réglementations ou si bien d'urbanisme
que que tous les autres qui puisse y
avoir
[Musique]
en bref la cpam des yvelines va bien
rester à mantes-la-jolie un temps
annoncé sur le départ vers poissy la
direction départementale de l'assurance
maladie va quitter ses locaux actuels
dès janvier prochain les services
administratifs et l'accueil du public
seront installés boulevard clemenceau
dans le quartier du val fourré toujours
à mantes-la-jolie donc et dans
l'immeuble qui a hébergé les impôts il
ya quelques années un déménagement
provisoire en attendant la construction
de locaux flambant neufs qui seront donc
construits d'ici deux ans est ce
toujours dans le quartier du val fourré
et direction rambouillet à présent la
bergerie nationale a accueilli le
week-end dernier le premier festival les
feuilles d'automne un rendez vous qui
avait pour but est de réunir des
artistes et des auteurs retour avec
michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
ala pirates de dix mille yves dans une
grange de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet le collectif hélium composé
d'artistes de la vallée de chevreuse
investi cette espèce de 170 m² à
l'occasion du festival des mots les
feuilles d'automne l'oeuvre a été
réalisée en deux jours avec six mètres
cubes d'ouvragé donné par emmaüs trappe
interpellées se questionner savoir ce
qu'on fait et élire savoir ce qu'on fait
ce qu'on peut faire aussi collectivement
c'est très important qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec tout ça et même avec des vieux
livres on peut on peut créer quelque
chose c'est très intéressant en plus
d'hélium les visiteurs ont également pu
voir des spectacles des ateliers mais
également assister à des tables rondes
les 16 et 17 octobre ce dimanche lors
antilles on est venu présenter un livre
qui parle d'un arbre de la forêt de
rambouillet j'avais entendu parler de ce
festival et et puis bah quand l'occasion
s'est présentée de pouvoir y participer
et y contribue et on a bien sûr tout mis
en oeuvre de manière à ce que je puisse
y participer et puis pouvoir échanger
avec avec mon public un public en plus
de connaisseur puisque il se promène
dans la forêt dans laquelle vit corpus
au total le festival a attiré plusieurs
centaines de personnes au regard du
succès rencontré les organisateurs
espèrent pérenniser le rendez vous
l'idée c'est que ça continue c'est pas
juste un événement une fois c'est se
donner un rendez-vous maintenant tous
les ans au travers du festival des mots
et puis d'aller en itinérance d'aller à
la rencontre des publics parmi les
publics les organisateurs voudrait
sensibiliser encore plus les scolaires
dans les prochaines éditions et les
inclure dans le projet l'année prochaine
le rendez vous devrait de nouveau se
tenir à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet
et puis si vous vous êtes baladé samedi
à la verrière vous avez dû forcément les
apercevoir ou tout du moins les entendre
près de 70 mustang étaient rassemblées
dans le parc du château est la commune
avec le must en club de france avec une
journée à l'américaine balade et baptême
était au programme nous avons pu
embarquer le récit de mélanie poker
[Musique]
étincelante rutilantes les mustangs ont
investi le parc du château de la
verrière en nombre ce samedi la ville a
partagé un peu d' american dream la
voiture est sortie en avril 64
1964 c'était à l'époque une voiture
destinée aux secrétaires aux assistantes
voiture bas de gamme destiné à
concurrencer les autres marques du
moment et une voiture à la carte plein
d'options ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
trouve peu de voitures avec le même
modèle les mêmes options
[Musique]
avec cette belle journée profitez de la
mustang comme il se doit c'est-à-dire le
coude à la portière et avec du plaisir
c'est une voiture plaisir au fait
comme car l'italie près de 70
passionnément gros du must en club
france sont venus avec des véhicules
deux premières cinquième et sixième
génération l'événement a débuté avec une
balade en vallée de chevreuse
l'engouement qu'elle procure le plaisir
on le remarque tout le temps
particulièrement en france il ya il dès
qu'on s'arrête tout le monde qu'il ya
nous voir c'est il ya un engouement du
public est fantastique et comme on
partage cette passion qu'on n'est pas un
club élitiste qui restons un peu chez
nous mais qui faisons profiter comme
aujourd'hui
et la luce tanguay la voiture de sport
la plus vendue au monde pour l'année
2019 et les curieux ont répondu présent
lors de cet événement la mairie évalue
le nombre de visiteurs à plus de mille
curieux avec le petit bouchon on peut
les voir tranquillement et à regarder
les petites merveilles et voitures ce
joli nom
on a une journée exceptionnelle surtout
nous avons envie de partir aux
etats-unis et pourquoi pas aux mustangs
de 1360 euros ont été récoltés au
bénéfice des restos du coeur lors des
baptêmes organisée dans l'après-midi une
remise de chèque va bientôt être
organisée par la commune une deuxième
édition est d'ores et déjà envisagée
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant ne
manquez pas le nouveau numéro du 7-8
culture célia 400 go vous emmène à la
batterie et de guyancourt pour découvrir
la programmation de la saison sur place
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]